So back in the 60s and 70s,
there was a researcher named John Calhoun,
and he did an experiment
where he created a perfect mouse Utopia.
He started with four males,
four females,
and he put them in this environment that was
perfectly catered to their every need.
They had an unlimited supply of food,
water, there was plenty of shelter,
plenty of nesting material,
and it was completely free of any predators.
At the beginning of the experiment,
things were going fine.
The mice were having babies,
they were happy,
they were eating a lot,
they were healthy,
and things were good.
But once the population hit around 600,
the population growth started to decline,
and their little mouse society
started to see a lot of problems.
My started splitting off into different groups,
and a lot of the males started to withdraw,
having no real role in society.
And they would all gather in these groups
and start just attacking each other.
The behaviors of the females change, too.
They begin needing to fulfill more aggressive roles
because the males were absent in those roles
in their nests.
And despite their every need being catered to,
the mothers started to abandon their babies
or even kill them.
The entire society quickly became very violent,
very hyper sexual.
And eventually,
the few mice who made it into adulthood,
having been around such unusual behaviors,
had no interest in mating and engaging with anyone.
And they would go up and Live in their own little
individual shelters
and just watch everything go down.
The low birth rate,
the high infant mortality rate,
those two things combined with the violence,
and eventually
the entire colony went extinct.
Calhoun referred to the process as behavioral sync,
and he found it really interesting that despite,
or maybe because of,
having every single need met,
the mass environment never even reached full capacity.